- So I'm really delighted
to introduce Liana Chua
who is a reader in anthropology
at Brunel University in London.
She received her PhD
in social anthropology
from the University of Cambridge
where she also held a research
fellowship in anthropology.
She has worked with
rural Bidayuh communities
in Sarawak, Malaysian Borneo since 2003
looking first at Christian
conversion and ethnic politics.
And more recently at
displacement environmental change
and world-making in the context
of dam construction and
resettlement schemes.
Now she's turning her research trajectory
towards a more than human
engagements in Borneo
and focusing on some
of the ethical dilemmas
associated with orangutan conservation.
She's widely published and has
a lot of wonderful articles
and books that I
recommend you all look at.
Her book is called
"The Christianity of Culture:
Conversion, Ethnic Citizenship,
and the Matter of Religion
in Malaysian Borneo"
which was published in 2012.
She's also the co-editor
of a volume called
Distributed Objects: Meaning
and Mattering after Alfred Gell
which is published in 2013
and her articles are
really quite wonderful.
I'll just mention a few.
There's a lot of them.
There's one called the
Troubled landscapes,
troubling anthropology:
co‐presence, necessity,
and the making of ethnographic knowledge
published in Journal of the
Royal Anthropological Institute
in 2015.
There's an American
ethnologist piece from 2012
called conversion continuity
and moral dilemmas
among Christian Bidayuhs
in Malaysian Borneo
and also a wonderful piece
called To know or not to know?
Practices of knowledge and ignorance
among Bidayuhs in an
'impurely' Christian world
also with Journal of the Royal
Anthropological Institute
Today's session will be
kind of a special experiment
in academic presentations.
I've asked Liana if
she's willing to engage
in a kind of talk show style format.
The goal is to introduce
her work to all of you
and to allow her to
chart some of the themes
that have been going through
these many interesting connections
and to introduce the
importance of Malaysian Borneo
to a wide interdisciplinary
audience of Southeast Asianist
and also people interested
in anthropology.
So the way this is gonna work
is we'll have a conversation
for about 20 to 30 minutes
and then after we do that, I'm
gonna open it up to questions
from the whole audience.
And I've asked Liana to
kind of speak broadly
in a way that can bring
people into her work.
So even if you haven't read her work yet
you'll get to learn a little
about it along the way.
So with that said, let's
turn to the conversation.
So firstly, thank you,
Liana for joining us.
And that was really
delightful to have you here.
- Hi, it's nice to meet
everyone and thank you very much
for such a lovely, a warm and
generous introduction Erik.
It's really nice to meet you.
- Yeah. So it's great to have you.
I wanna ask you about the
places you work in Borneo
and some of the people
that you've come to know
in your field work.
So if you can just kind
of speak in an open sense
about where do you work
and who do you work with
and what are some of the major
issues confronting people
in the region and what are
some of the core themes
that you see animating your
work and how they've emerged
from your long-term research
in Malaysian Borneo?
- Sure. Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, so I guess I sort of see myself
as an anthropologist of Borneo
and the kind of broader sense
in the sense that I try to
approach Borneo as an Island
that's very much a sort
of interconnected space
with many socio-cultural, linguistic,
religious, political formations
but also environmental events
and processes and changes
that transcend contemporary
national boundaries.
So in that sense, I'm very interested
in the sorts of flows and connections,
but also kind of gaps
in tensions that go on
within this broad Island.
But having said that the bulk
of my research since 2003
has been with Bidayuhs as Eric mentioned.
So Bidayuhs are small indigenous group.
They live in the East Malaysian
State of Sarawak in Borneo
and they live in the sort
of mountainous hinterlands
of the State Capital, Kuching.
And so for my PhD, I
lived for about 15 months
which is fairly standard for
anthropological field work
in a fairly large Bidayuh village.
And this village was a really
interesting place to be in
because it was in the
middle of this transition
from a kind of
rice-planting adamistic past
to a very self-consciously
modern urbanized
Christian present and future.
And I kind of turned
up towards the tail end
of that process.
And one of the most interesting things
about doing research at that time
was that although the
vast majority of people
had converted to Christianity,
various denominations of
Christianity by that stage,
many of them still
remembered what it was like
to do the old rituals.
They had sort of firsthand experience
of what it was like to
convert to Christianity
relatively recently kind of
in the last 10, 20 years.
And so there was that.
There was this kind of
really rich living archive
of the conversion experience
but there were also about 10
elderly animus practitioners
who are still carrying on and
still doing the odd rituals
and actually being helped in various ways
by their sort of younger
Christian Kayan neighbors.
So it was a fascinating time to be there
and so that was what eventually
gave rise to my book.
And some of my earlier
publications on Christianity
where I kind of looked
at Bidayuh's experiences
of converting to Christianity
got kind of enmeshed
with their experiences
of contemporary ethnic
religious politics in Malaysia,
which as many of you know is dominated
by kind of Malaysia Muslim majority,
but also how this was impacting
on their own internal
relations within the village
and the ways they were
negotiating their relationships
with both the old animus
practitioners and the old spirits
were still very much
around and very present
in their lives.
And so I've written about that
and maybe you can talk
about that bit later on.
So that was my PhD.
After my PhD from about in 2007
I began doing what turned into
a quite long-term project.
I'm still doing it.
That traces the experiences of four small
and relatively remote Bidayuh villages
that got caught up in a dam construction
and resettlement project.
So I basically trace the
experiences of these communities
all the way from the sort of preparations,
when they were thinking about compensation
who was going to go where,
who was gonna move to
the resettlement site
to a very sort of fractures
and very protracted legal
case that some people fought
in order to prevent
being moved to the site.
They wanted to move up to a new site
on their ancestral land above the dam
all the way through to
the inundation phase
from about 2015 onwards.
And now I'm looking at
the post inundation phase
where you've got these people
including three very small villages
that are in fact now above
the dam as they were hoping
who are really struggling
to kind of create new
and livable futures for
themselves in this new space
where actually there was no real...
They weren't really meant
to exist in these spaces,
in these kinds of brand new
wooden villages that were built
above a major development project.
They were never meant to be there.
And so it's been really interesting
kind of writing about these experiences.
And I'm now trying to
work on my second book
which will be a sort of
more than human ethnography
of how these different effected villages
try to navigate their
relationships with each other,
but also with a developmental state
with various indigenous
rights activists and lawyers
who got involved in the case
with different Christian churches
all had very different kinds
of spiritual and political
stakes in this situation.
And also with place spirits
and with the changing landscape
and with the Christian god.
I mean, these were all
very sort of active players
during my field work.
And I've found a kind of
more than human lands,
a very useful way of thinking
through these extremely sort of visceral,
very sort of material experiences.
So that as opposed to a bit,
and also my current work
but what I'm actually doing right now
is a sort of extension of
this earlier interest, I guess
in more than human anthropology,
but also the ways in which
rural and indigenous communities
in Borneo engage with global movements
and kind of entire complexes.
So at the moment I've
got a couple of projects
going on the global nexus
of orangutan conservation.
The first one is a fairly sort of
classic anthropological
multi-sided exploration
of how the different bits,
people, things, ideas
of this conservation nexus
has kind of move around
shape each other, shape
realities on the ground
or very often fail to there.
There are many tensions and
conflicts within this network,
as you can imagine.
And so I've got a team of
researchers working with me.
I can talk about that a little bit.
And what we're trying to do is basically
use in-depth anthropological research
at different sites of
orangutan conservation,
ranging from little villages,
caught up in wild orangutan
conservation schemes
in Central Kalimantan in Borneo
to orangutan charities in the UK
that are raising funds for these schemes.
And we're trying to sort of build up
a more kind of holistic picture
of how this one conservation
nexus is or isn't working
against the backdrop of the Anthropocene.
And that's a whole other discussion
that we can have later on.
So that's one project.
The second project is
slightly more unusual
I think for an anthropologist,
it's a more sort of applied anthropology
conservation collaboration
where I'm working with Eric Meijaard
who's quite a senior orangutan
conservation scientist
and we're basically trying
to use ethnographic insights
and methods to devise better ways
of mitigating orangutan
killing in rural Borneo.
And more importantly for me to
try and help conservationist
to engage better with local communities
in more kind of
contextually specific ways.
So those are kind of the three main bits
of my research trajectory.
I mean, in terms of the core themes
I think maybe I've
already touched on them.
There's a sort of enduring interest I have
in more than human interactions.
And by this, I include
everything from objects
and plants and animals to
spirits that you can't see.
And I think I'm also very interested
in trying to use a sort
of grounded perspective,
in-depth ethnographic research
that takes local concepts
and experiences seriously
as a way of cutting these big ideas
like the Anthropocene or like development
or Christianity down to size
and to try and understand
the kinds of local faces
that they acquire on the ground.
So, yeah, that's a sort of quick...
That's a really quick
overview of what I'm doing.
- I was muted.
So fascinating to hear you just walk us
through the broad trajectory
of all your research.
There's so many tangents
that are all entangled
around these core ideas
of the more than human.
I'd actually like to hear
you talk a little bit
about what you see the contribution
of more than human anthropology doing,
because it's rising as a field these days
but I also would like to ask you
because in some of your writing,
you developed some critiques
of the ontological turn
and let's mindful of the audience
not everyone in the
audience will necessarily
be an anthropologist per se.
And so if you could explain
the connection to your critique
of the ontological turn, sort
of situate that a little bit,
explain what you think they're doing
and why you're a little bit hesitant
about some of the aspects,
but also inspired it seems to
me by them a little bit too.
And then also talk a little bit
about what you think the importance
of the more than human turn
in anthropology is too.
It's a lot. So you can separate.
You can talk about only one
of them if you want, but-
- Well, I mean, I'll start
with the ontological turn
but just kind of give me a push
if I forget about the other bits.
- Sure.
- Yeah. So, wow.
Where do I start?
Okay, so the ontological turn
is essentially a sort of movement.
Well let's call it an umbrella term
that draws together a bunch
of very different approaches that emerged
in and beyond anthropology,
across the social sciences and humanities
around the late 2000s
or mid to late 2000s.
And that was most strongly articulated
by a group of scholars in about
the late 2000s, early 2010s
particularly a group of anthropologists
from Cambridge at the
time who actually came up
with the phrase, the ontological turn.
So what they did was they
kind of drew together
all of these different developments,
which were connected as they saw it
and gave it a name and said,
this is the future of anthropology.
And so essentially what
these anthropologists argued
at the time was that up to that point,
anthropologists had failed
to really take seriously.
We use this term or not take seriously,
the various beliefs, political concepts,
experiences of the people
that they worked with
because they were unable
to apprehend these beliefs
and concepts and practices and so on
on ontological turns.
which is to say that if, for
example you saw a bunch of...
If somebody told you that
shape is my cape is my ancestor
or is that power, that powder is powerful.
You as the kind of Cartesian
rational anthropologists
would say, well that's just a kind of...
That's a cultural gloss
of an ontological reality.
That's not really power.
That's just powder that my
informants believes is power,
or that cape is not really an ancestor.
That's just the kind of...
That's just a material object.
It's just that they believe
that this is their ancestor.
And so proponents of the ontological turn
basically argued that this
sort of smarter than that
as one of them put a tendency was actually
not a very ethical way
of doing anthropology
but also not a very
conceptually creative way
of doing anthropology
because you weren't
then always going to be
sort of hamstrung by your own
kind of ontological schema
and your own assumptions,
which meant that it would be impossible
to fully engage with these
different people and concepts
on their own terms.
And so in place of what they saw is,
is very inadequate concept.
And I should say that I don't think
they were entirely fair either
about sort of criticizing
previous generations
for not taking people seriously,
but in place of what they
saw as this kind of flawed
approach to anthropology, they took
a sort of deliberately naive approach.
Which basically aimed to take
the interlocutors concepts,
words, beliefs at face
value on ontological turns.
So if you say that cape is your ancestor
in your ethnography you
say you don't write.
They believe that that
cape is their ancestor.
You just say that cape is their ancestor
and you run with it.
And then from that point
on, once you've kind of made
that sort of ontological
leap and started to engage
with these local other
radically different concepts
on their own terms, then
the whole sort of process
of conceptual creativity
and theoretical creativity
could begin.
And that was for
ontological turn proponents
that was the kind of most
exciting bit of anthropology.
That point where you confronted
this radical alterity
you had your own presumption shaken up,
and then you came to this new
and exciting understanding
of the world or this concept
or belief or whatever
and then where she were off, right.
And then you could sort of
talk to other anthropologists
about what you've found.
So that's essentially it.
So I think in many ways
the ontological turn
does provide a very useful
kind of methodological
and analytical approach to anthropologists
especially of Southeast Asia,
where as you know there's a
huge amount of heterogeneity
that there's so many different
sort of linguistic, cultural,
religious complex has so
many different kinds of
social formations, politics and so on,
that are also co-existing
with very, very strong
and very influential homogenizing forces
like states, nationalist movements,
sort of Orthodox Islam,
Orthodox Christianity
all of which have a sort of tendency
to suppress that heterogeneity
and have a tendency to just kind of squash
that sort of difference in the interest
of creating a more kind of
purified or unified whole.
And I think in that sense,
maintaining that sort of
ontological turny impulse
I guess, ontological turny.
Yeah. Anyway.
That impulse to kind of push back
against homogenizing forces,
to avoid explaining things away
by recourse to your own
concepts and your own values
can be extremely useful to
anthropologists of Southeast Asia
as we grapple with all these kinds
of different possibilities,
different life worlds,
just kind of different
ontologies you might argue.
And actually here,
I think we might maybe
learn a thing or two
from people like Marisol de la Cadena,
another sort of contributor
to more ontologically
inflicted anthropology
with her work on indigenous
cosmic politics in the Andes
where she does in fact write to adopter
to kind of engage with these
radically different concepts
on their own terms.
So that's the kind of...
That's a very quick summary
of the ontological turn
and why it might be useful
to Southeast Asianist
but as Eric, you noted
I do have some concerns
with the ontological turn.
So I'm gonna try and
summarize them really quickly.
I think my first concern
and is that even though,
let's call them ontologists
just for short, right?
Even though ontologists
do say quite explicitly
that they're not trying to
sort of reify otherness and difference,
then they're not going
out there looking for
sort of noble savages or
exotic eithers or whatever.
They're saying it's about
anything that's unfamiliar
or different that sort of challenges
your preconceived notions,
coulees or alterity.
So even though they're
not explicitly saying that
they're looking for a
radically cultural other,
I think in practice,
what an ontological approach tends to do
is replicate a dichotomy that has
kind of haunted anthropology
since its inception
which is that dichotomy
between the sort of
Western implicitly
Cartesian Euro-American self
with all its baggage
and the cultural other.
So when you start to read quite carefully
what ontologists are writing,
even though they never
explicitly talk about
this being about otherness and
radically different people,
their work is implicitly addressed
towards a we that is composed of people
who are seemed to have
a kind of Western Cartesian background.
Anthropologists for whom that
kind of leap of understanding
it's really, really difficult
because they're facing such
radically other concepts
and those radically other concepts
always seem to be anti Cartesian,
or just kind of these
conceptual foils to Western...
To a very hackneyed understanding
of what Western thought is.
As you can imagine, I felt personally
quite uncomfortable with this as well
as a sort of Singaporean anthropologist
who didn't necessarily see myself
or kind of recognize
myself as part of that us,
as opposed to that them.
So when I was doing field work
in the village for example,
when people talked about
spirits living in trees
and little demons that
could suck your blood,
all these things I've
grown up with this stuff.
It was not a huge conceptual
leap for me to understand
what was going on and to
take this stuff seriously.
I didn't need to explain these way.
I mean, I felt...
I got these shivers when people
talked about these things
because I recognize them.
So I think there is that problem
that even though they don't
necessarily explicitly try to
there is a tendency to kind of fall back
on this rather problematic
dichotomy within anthropology.
And I guess sort of linked to that,
is that I do have some
concerns with the position
and the role of the anthropologist
in the ontological turn.
And this was very much
the basis of my critique
in the Troubled landscapes
paper that you read Eric,
where what you're essentially doing
by kind of privileging that encounter
between the anthropologist
and that moment of radical alterity
that sort of unexplainable,
unfamiliar moment
where your whole world
gets kind of blown apart.
What you're kind of doing,
I think is inadvertently
centering the anthropologist.
And you're basically
turning the anthropologist
into this kind of rather
invulnerable, impermeable arbiter
who has the complete
capacity and thus authority
to decide which concepts, which beliefs
should and shouldn't be
treated on ontological turns.
Which of these you're gonna run with
as the basis of your kind of
conceptual creative process.
And I guess my problem with this is that
it tends to sort of purify
the field work and counter.
It sort of, it strips
away all the confusion,
the mistranslation, the misunderstandings,
the tensions that you inevitably
encounter in the field.
There's so many times when
I've been told something
by my friends,
I've taken it really seriously.
I've written it down.
And then the next day they're like,
oh, by the way that was just a joke.
You didn't really believe that. Did you?
That thing about spirits?
And you get so much of this in the field
or you get people kind of
deliberately pulling you
into their own political projects
and kind of making up all sorts of things
that will boost their
position, whatever, right?
So there are lots of these
kinds of little messes
and complications of
co-presence as I call it
that you will find within
the actual experience
of field work that kind
of gets stripped away
when you start trying to approach things
in this deliberately naive manner.
And so what I guess I was calling for
in this Troubled landscapes paper
was basically more sort
of more humble approach
to anthropology that didn't
just kind of shine a spotlight
on the anthropologist
and kind of privileged the
anthropologist as the locus
of all that was exciting and anthropology.
Once you've got these wonderful concepts
off you go, go talk to your
mates in the ivory tower
and kind of make up new theories, great.
That was precisely what
I was trying to avoid.
And I was...
What I was basically saying was no,
we need to try and ground these encounters
in the networks of
co-presence in the field,
which we can't afford to
erase from our ethnographies
and of which we are inevitably
part as anthropologists.
So that's kind of where my discomfort
with the ontological turn lies.
So that was-
- No, that's really...
This is fascinating.
The thing that I find so fascinating
about your career and
what you've just described
is that your critique
of the ontological turn
"Takes seriously" the impulse
of the ontological turn,
which they claim in some ways
is to take seriously other perspectives,
but then you recognize in the process
it's inadvertently privileged
the anthropologists.
So it's a very interesting critique
that is sensitive to the
ambitions of the turn
but also recognizing its
internal contradictions
which is quite interesting.
I wonder if you could take
us into Borneo a little bit
and in that essay where
you're talking about this
and describe a term that you use in there.
You say there's a risk
in the ontological turn
to have a proclivity to gloss
over local heterogeneities,
which I found really gripping
because it reminded me
of my own field work
in Southeast Asia where
there's lots of heterogeneities
and whenever you want to
claim that there's a kind of
an ontology of something
it can be quite tricky.
But I wondered if you
could describe a couple
of the heterogeneities that
maybe like let off a light bulb
for you or something like that.
And then after that
we'll turn to talk about
your orangutan work.
And then after that, we'll open it up
to questions from the audience.
- Okay, great.
Thank you.
Yeah, absolutely.
So this kind of goes back to
my earlier point, I guess,
about how ontologists kind of hold,
I guess they privilege
that moment of encounter
between the anthropologist
and the radical other,
the alterity.
And that's kind of like the moment,
when everything gets really exciting.
So you kind of...
You would often hear
ontologists saying in person,
I'm not really that interested
in the kind of boring everyday stuff.
I just...
I'm just really interested
in that unusual moment
because that for me is
the most important thing.
And I guess one of...
No shoots.
So one of the consequences
of keeping that encounter,
that interface between
anthropologists and other
at the forefront of the ontological turn
is that that whole other bit gets squashed
in the same way that the whole sort
of anthropologist bit
gets squashed, right?
So there's another sort of
edited volume I recently did
called Who are we? Which is...
Which was very much
about trying to question
this rather on unthinking,
unproblematic invocation
of the sort of anthropological
we, as the imagined audience
who exactly are this we
that we're talking about?
Anyway, that's anthropologist.
So we've got the sort of
local heterogeneity here.
Yeah, so there were many,
many moments in the field
where I sort of encountered
these sorts of divisions
and this was precisely what
made me quite suspicious
of any sort of program that tried
to make vast sweeping
statements about the Bidayuh
or about indigenous people as a whole,
because this was...
It was I feel like a bit
of a kind of misery guts,
but, you know, it's very, very difficult
to kind of run with those projects
when you're very aware of
the ethnographic complexity
and the messiness of what's
going on in the ground.
So one example, which I mentioned
was different Christian
views of the old people,
the old animus practitioners
and the old spirits
that were still around,
which I talked about
in this other paper, Eric,
which you read, To know or not to know?
And this was a really
interesting sort of tension
that I encountered in the field.
Which was, what on earth do
you do with these old guys
who are still insisting on
practicing the old rituals?
How do you deal with the
kinds of spirit realities
that these rituals bring to the village?
Because the thing that
everybody understood
was that even though most people
had converted to Christianity,
the old spirits were still there.
You know they...
As long as people continued
to believing in them,
practicing the old rituals,
doing things that would engage with them,
the old spirits would stay around.
They were less powerful
and less influential now
because everyone was,
most people were Christian
as they said, but they were there.
And that was a problem
because a lot of Christians
didn't necessarily
want to get embroiled in
relations with these old spirits.
And so one of the
interesting things I found
was that Christians
views of the old spirits
and the old rituals varied
according to their denomination
which I wasn't expecting because
coming in from the outside
I had a very kind of dim
view of missionaries.
I just thought, yeah,
you know, nasty bunch,
foisting a foreign
religion on these people.
I mean, it turns out Christianity
was really, really important
to their lives and that's fine.
And what I found was that the
Anglicans and the Catholics
whose missionaries had been there
since the late 19th century
but had never really converted
people very successfully
until about the 1960s and
'70s for various reasons
had a very sort of accommodating
view of the old rituals.
As far as they were concerned,
the old rituals worship the same god.
So they used the same term, the Bau
which was the Bau was the
animus word for the Supreme god.
And the Bau has become the sort of
Catholic and Anglican
word for god the Father.
The practitioners weren't
doing anything bad.
I mean, if you were doing anything bad,
you'd go into a lot of trouble
'cause people were very
aware of kind of black magic,
but as far as they were concerned,
most of the old rituals were
designed to bring good things
to the village and bless
the village's inhabitants.
So no big deal, right?
You just sort of carry on helping them.
And they also saw it as an
important kind of familial
or neighborly obligation to
help these older villages.
So it was very much a way of kind of
cementing their existing social ties
with people who as far as they
were concerned needed help.
So anytime you went to one of
these rituals in the village
you would find your 10
animus practitioners
doing their thing, doing the
main chance and the offerings
and dancers and everything,
but all around them would be Christians.
And the Christians would be there
building the altars for
them, going up to the jungle
to collect the bamboo that
they needed for these things,
cooking the offerings,
killing the sacrificial pigs,
playing the gongs, everything.
And they saw this as a
really important part
of their kind of duty.
The kind of the people
who didn't agree with this
were members of the evangelical church.
So this is the Sidang Injil Borneo.
It's a sort of homegrown
non-denominational evangelical church
which something you've heard of.
These guys arrived in
the village in the 1990s
and the first converts were converts
from Anglicanism and Catholicism.
So there was already
a bit of tension there
in that the church was
seen as kind of poaching
some of the existing Christians
and making them convert
to a different sort of Christianity.
They had a very...
They had a much more
kind of puritanical view
of what was and wasn't acceptable.
No drinking, no smoking,
no gambling which was big.
It was a big sort of
lubricant of sociality
in the village with all the
Catholics and Anglicans did.
And they were really terrified.
I mean, I think they were
actually quite scared
of the old rituals in the
sense that they saw them
as the work of Satan that
would bring evil spirits
into the village.
And so whenever these rituals took place,
there was always trouble
because any time the old practitioners
came into contact with
the SIB, the evangelicals
they get a really sort
of aggressive reception
and many evangelicals would often try
and sort of convert them
and tell them that they
were going to hell.
And their souls would not get
to heaven and it was
all gonna be horrible.
And so that was one
really interesting kind of
local heterogeneity that I
hadn't really expected it
to come across when I was
actually doing field work.
But which became quite a defining feature
of my understanding of Christianity.
And of course the same thing applies
to what people thought of the old spirits.
Nobody could decide what
would actually happen
to the old spirits and how
exactly to engage with them.
So there was some people who...
Especially the older
ones, if they'd grown up
knowing how to deal with the old spirits
if the encountered them in
the forest or in the village,
they would just do the old things
and then say a Christian prayer
at the end just to be safe.
There were younger adults
who would do a kind of
half-hearted response as they should
and then say a prayer just to be safe.
And then there were younger
adults who just refuse to know
in many cases.
They actually actively
cultivated a kind of agnosis
or kind of not knowing precisely
because they were really...
They really didn't want to
sort of end up acquiring
the sort of knowledge
that would be necessary
for them to engage in these
relations with the old spirits.
Because the principle was once you knew
what to do if a spirit
tried to talk to you
or send you a message and
you didn't actually do it
you were gonna be in really deep trouble.
And so a lot of the
younger people were like,
well, actually, you know what?
I don't wanna know about this.
Which in turn meant they
never wanted to talk to me
about it.
So I'd be there with my notebook.
Oh my god, you wouldn't
believe what I've just heard
about this and that the old people
didn't tell me that much either
'cause they didn't wanna
get me into trouble, right.
They were like, ah, you're
already useless, right?
You can't weave baskets.
You can't plant rice very well.
I'm not gonna tell you how
to deal with these spirits.
No, no, no no.
I'm just gonna tell you
really sort of generic stuff.
So I write down very generic stuff.
So they were kind of protecting me,
but the moment I go and talk
to some of the younger people
they're just be like, I don't
wanna know, not interested.
So there was a whole kind of spectrum
of different ways of relating
or in this case actually not
relating to the old spirits.
That again, it's really interesting stuff
but if you take a sort of
ontological turn approach to it,
you're not gonna capture any of this stuff
because you're gonna be running
with the most exciting points
where it's about the spirit concept.
And then you kind of run
off with this concept
but you're not gonna
capture that heterogeneity.
- That's really fascinating.
In some ways you've foreclosed
what you're able to look into
because you're looking for alterity.
Whereas the most important
story might be right there
in front of your nose.
We're running close to the time
I wanted to a lot to our conversation
but I wanna make sure
that you say a few words
about your new research
on orangutan conservation.
So if you could speak for
a few minutes about that
just to share that with our audience,
and then after that, I'll turn in moderate
open question and answer
with the rest of the people
who've come today.
- Yeah. Okay.
So I think I very briefly touched on
what my two projects in
orangutan conservation are doing.
Maybe what I could do
is share a little bit
about what we're currently finding.
So what we're basically in
the middle of these projects,
most of us have kind of
finished most of our field work.
There was a bit of
disruption due to COVID.
So we're not quite there yet
but we've got some really
interesting initial insights.
So as I said, I've got one, two, three,
three colleagues we're currently looking
into human orangutan relations,
or actually the lag they're off
on the ground in rural Borneo.
And one of the really interesting things
we found is this very marked contrast
between the sort of hyper
visibility of orangutans
in the West
as these very charismatic,
very famous icons of extinction, right?
You think extinction,
rainforests, orangutans again.
And then on the other side,
and in places like Borneo and Sumatra,
you've got the relative
invisibility and insignificance.
And what we tend to find
is that for the most part,
rural villages in Borneo especially,
we haven't done that
much work in Sumatra yet,
but we're getting similar input
from people we know there.
For the most part, villages
are just not interested
in orangutans.
They're kind of the things
that you might encounter
in the forest occasionally,
but they're not particularly special.
They're not particularly
creatures that you wanna form
any relations with.
Every now and then they
turn into these pests
because when it's durian season
and the trees are all fruiting,
out come the orangutans.
And so my PhD student, Paul actually
had some really interesting kind of notes
from his conversations with farmers.
Apparently orangutans are
seen as particularly naughty
because when they raid durian trees,
they don't just eat the durians,
which is completely understandable,
villagers are eating durians too.
They throw the unripe
durians onto the ground
which is really antisocial.
So, you know, they...
So by and large peoples...
They're not companion
species, let's put it this way
in any sense of the term.
For the most part there was
just no interest in orangutans.
They're occasional pests. You
don't like having them around.
What is though is that, the main ways
in which orangutans become
visible and significant to people
in these places is through conservation.
So in many ways, what we're
finding is that field work
actually involves very little sort of
physical encounters with orangutans
and very little kind of evidence
of human orangutan relations necessarily
apart from pet-keeping, which
I'll talk about in a second.
And actually much more...
It's a much more to do
with villages relations
with conservationists
who are in many ways,
making the orangutans much
more kind of significant
and in a way, much more dangerous
than they used to be in the past,
because orangutans are
protected and people are aware
that they're protected
and that you could get
into a lot of trouble for harming
or capturing an orangutan,
which for the most part,
you've just never seen
as particularly important or
special or worth protecting.
And so what we're kind
of seeing emerge here
is quite a significant amount of tension
between people in Borneo especially
and conservationists
who are very often seen
as caring more about animals than people.
So you kind of hear things like,
well we are the real orangutan.
Yeah. The real people of the forest.
But why are they...
Why are these foreigners
throwing all this money
and care and everything
at saving these kind of this one ape?
Why just this one ape?
Why are you building these
huge rehabilitation centers
with state-of-the-art
x-rays, medical supplies,
nappies, milk powder when we
don't even have this stuff?
So it's a really kind of
tense situation on the ground.
There's a whole kind of spectrum
of different conservationist as well.
So that kind of adds to
the complexity of things.
But I guess that that sort of tension
has really been the kind of
main feature of our field work
in these areas.
I just wanna touch very
briefly on this issue
of pet-keeping as well,
which is in that article that I sent you.
There is kind of one exception
to this lack of interest in orangutans,
or kind of antagonism towards orangutans.
And that's pet-keeping,
that's when rural villages
very often the mother orangutan is killed
while trying to get fruit or
whatever or in somebody's farm.
They take the baby as a pet.
People are aware that you can sell the pet
for quite a lot of money
but some villages just
choose to keep pets.
Yes, pets.
And it's not very common
and it's quite dispersed,
but it does happen.
And in these cases, what we tend to find
is that these villages see themselves
as kind of carers of orangutans.
So they see themselves as
having save these poor babies
who are completely helpless
from a very cruel jungle
where they might get eaten
or killed or died of starvation,
which is probably true.
You know, they see themselves
as kind of investing
into these creatures,
nurturing them, feeding them,
paying money for them, buying
them nappies, whatever.
And so they're not...
As far as they're concerned,
they're not harming them.
But then conservationists
become aware of this fact,
this often results in quite a kind of
dramatic orangutan confiscation operation
where these conservationists will turn up
with members of the local
wildlife and forest authorities.
'Cause there's always gonna
be a member of the government
with them.
They turn up, they
confiscate this orangutan.
They never...
They don't offer compensation
because as far as they're
concerned it's illegal.
And then they take into
these rehabilitation centers
where they get cared for,
they get fed, they get
cuddled, they get nurtured.
As far as villages are
concerned in much the same way
as they were doing it in the village.
And so this is,
one of those really interesting
kind of ethical dilemmas
I think,
that's been haunting
me during my research.
And so just very briefly,
I think the sort of three
main ethical concerns
that kind of smash up
against each other here.
One of them is the sort of
cultural relativist impulse
that many anthropologists
animated by, right?
I mean, my first reaction was like,
well, why shouldn't these
people be allowed to have
whatever relations they
want with orangutans?
You know, why not?
You know, this is
colonialism, this is bad.
And then you call it the whole sort of,
well which comes into this
sort of more than human turn
which I realize I didn't
really talk about,
but this is part of this
sort of multi-species turn
in anthropology
where you start to think
about animals as agents
and animals as kind of
beings with affective ties
to humans and you think,
well, okay, what if that,
you watched some of these pet videos,
pet confiscation videos,
and the baby orangutan
obviously doesn't want
to leave it's its owner
and you think, oh, no, what about
the feelings of this poor orangutan?
Why should it be put through
this traumatic separation?
And then the third sort of problem is that
the main problem is that in reality
this sort of pet-keeping
can be extremely damaging.
Villagers don't tend to know
how to take care of orangutans.
They feed them rice,
condensed snow, chocolates.
Very often, they end up
getting malnourished or ill.
They become too big to control.
They get chained up, chuffed
into really crappy boxes.
And actually, in that case
I think the conservation is all right.
They're actually saving the orangutan
from what could be a
really, really nasty fate
much later on.
And there's no resolution
to these impulses,
but that's kind of one example of
the kinds of ethical
dilemmas that our research
is also trying to foreground.
Anyway, I've spoken a
lot, so I'm gonna stop.
- Well, thank you.
You've spoken a lot
but you've given us a lot to think about,
and I'm sure that our audience
has a lot of questions
for you.
So what we'll do here is I'll be...
I'll moderate the questions
using the Zoom interface.
So those of you who have any questions
if you can use the Hand Raise function
that will help me out.
But if you can't use
the Hand Raise function
turn on your camera and
wave your hand wildly
And I'll try my best to notice you.
I see that Michael Dove has his hand up
using the Hand Raise function.
So we'll start with Michael.
Go ahead, Michael.
- Thanks, Eric.
Fascinating chat, which
I've immensely enjoyed.
I wonder if we could go
back right to the beginning
when you talked about
your work with the Bidayuh
in transition.
So I'm wondering were the
Bidayuh ever not in transition?
But Borneo has a very rich history
and it almost to talk about
transition and pre-transition
almost sounds like we're
talking about a period
of no history.
- Yeah. Thank you.
I mean, I should clarify
that I'm talking about
one of many, many transitional periods
that Bidayuhs have gone through.
So people talked about it as
a significant period of change
and that was kind of
the sort of local lingo
that I was picking up on
this idea of borrowing
which is really quite fundamental
sort of transformation
of their society.
And it was quite interesting that,
I mean absolutely from a kind
of analytical point of view,
I'm completely with you.
They've always been in transition
and they've always engaged
with wider forces in the world
that they engaged with
what a trade networks
for centuries before that.
They were very much some
of the earliest supporters
of the Brook State, which was interesting.
They've been some really
interesting sort of analysis
of the relationships that they formed
with the government
and they took that the
British colonial government.
So they've been going through
various stages of transition,
I guess.
I mean, maybe transition
isn't even the best word
because this is very
much part of a continuum
of engaging with various external,
foreign, regional,
local forces and agents.
The reason I described it as
a transition was as I said,
my attempt to mirror
what Bidayuhs themselves
were describing as a major
change in their lives.
And there's major change was
conversion to Christianity
as far as they were concerned.
This was huge.
And it entailed a much more
sort of fundamental overhaul
of their social relations
and their kind of cosmologies
and religious practices.
Then some of their other engagements
with outside forces did.
For example with missionaries
who were hanging around in
the area in the 19th century
and early 20th century
but who never converted them.
So in that sense it was
my attempt to also capture
what people saw as a
significant period of change
leading to the present.
But I'm absolutely with you.
They've, you know...
that in other words, they kind of
static original romantic past
they've always engaged with
the world in various ways.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, Liana.
The next question is from Al Lim,
who's a PhD in student
in the anthropology
department here at Yale.
- Hi, Liana, thank you so
much for your presentation.
It's super fascinating
to think about the ways
people rationalize these
kinds of displacement.
I'm thinking about areas
or to work in Vietnam
and kind of work in the
Macular Hole and the Mitson
and just across Asia.
So, but what specific kind
of question about your site,
you talk about in your article
Gifting, Dam(n)ing and the
Ambiguation of Development.
This kind of Christian framework
that trumps Bidayuh to the
Malaysia development state.
So I'm wondering this kind of syncretism,
is it a mode of resistance
or is it a coping mechanism
and how might this have changed over time?
So you talked about the
kind of planning phase
of the during phase and the post phase.
So I'm just wondering how this kind
of mode of rationalization
changes over time.
And I know you wrote the
duty and piece at the end
so I was wondering if you
could speak a little bit
to that as well.
Thank you.
- Okay. Wow.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, I don't really know
if it's a sort of resistance
or coping mechanism.
I mean, in a way I'm trying to refrain.
I'm doing my own ambiguation in the sense
that I'm trying to refrain from saying,
well, this is the explanation,
this is basically the
function that it's serving.
I guess the point of that piece
was to try and reverse the usual way
that we tend to view sort
of people's engagements
with development projects,
rather than trying to use something
like a sort of for Cody
and governmentality lens
to understand how people
become subjects of development.
I tried to kind of reverse it and say,
okay, how does development
become Christianized?
How does it become mythologized?
Looking through these
sort of indigenous ideas.
And I would consider Christianity
indigenous in its own way.
It's become a significant
cultural concept.
And I guess if I had to...
If you sort of pin me down,
I'd probably say that Christianity
is a sort of creative mechanism,
more than anything else.
It's been an incredibly
sort of powerful means
through which my interlocutors
have managed to create
realities for themselves
in ways that were previously inconceivable
within the framework of the sort of
Malaysian developmental state.
So I've actually currently got an article
that's just been accepted
in current anthropology.
And it's looking at...
It basically looks at the
sort of Christian dimensions
of this legal case that they fought
and tries to understand how for many of,
even though the case itself
was sort of fought...
Was fought in legal, in the
terms of indigenous rights
and sort of legal rights
behind the scenes it was all about god.
It was all about them
being good moral Christians
and trying to enact a sort
of politically engaged
form of Christianity in the world
which in fact kind of led them
to desert the Anglican Church on Merce
and moved to this West
Malaysian charismatic church
because they thought the Anglican church
was just kind of too
tied up with the state.
And god was a big player in this, right?
So it became a very sort of
powerful productive force
through which they could actually make
this new village above the dam a reality.
And as far as they were
concerned, this was god's doing.
I mean, the lawyers helped
but this was definitely know
a big cosmological fight
that they won 'cause they
were good Christians.
So I guess that's one way of
kind of rethinking development.
Yeah, the durian piece.
So you're talking about
durian diplomacies?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So what's happened, right?
Just to bring you up to date is that
these guys eventually won the right to...
Well, it's a bit tricky.
So they got...
They forced the state to
recognize their ancestral rights
to the land above the dam.
Unfortunately, the state refused,
still refuses to recognize
their right to have a village
on that site which was
kind of their point, right?
So they went and built
this village from scratch
before they even won the case.
And they're living there now,
but because the state
is not supporting it,
it's refused to give it
subsidies for for pesticides,
none of the usual solar
panels, money for bamboo,
water pipe systems, anything.
They're trying to...
They become sort of entrepreneurial
and they're always been entrepreneurial.
They've always been been selling pepper
and rubber and cocoa depending
on what the prices are like
but they're kind of striking
out on their own right now
which is really, really interesting.
And one of the things that they've done
is they've worked with this
(speaks in foreign language)
So this Chinese businessmen,
who has a durian plantation
growing Musang King
which like is a sort of
premium brand of durian
that the China market pays
a huge amount of money for.
He has this plantion up
in Cameron Highlands.
And because these guys
were up in the hills
he's got them to transplant
some of these Musang King
seedlings over to their land
and they're growing
these Musang King durians
and marrying them with the
local variant as they say
so that they all become
this kind of super hybrid,
kind of indigenous durians.
And the hope is that they'll
eventually sell these durians
to the Chinese market
and make a lot of money.
So that's a new sort of
strategy that they're using
to make the most of
their current situation.
- Thank you, Liana.
We have a question from Ling Zhang.
Ling Zhang, do you mind
introducing yourself?
And also before you ask your question.
- Sure. Thank you.
Thank you so much for this wonderful talk.
Hi Chua.
I'm not an anthropologist.
I am actually a historian for China.
I am working on environmental history.
So your talk is a fascinating,
it teaches me a lot about
the ongoing discourses
in your discipline, in your field.
So I entered this conversation
a few minutes later
so you might have already
touched upon this.
I notice in the talk...
In the title of your
talk there dams there.
So I might have missed the
conversation about that.
Can you say something about dams?
And also I noticed in your talk
and in several of your publication,
you mentioned troubled landscapes.
So could you please also say something
about the troubled landscapes.
So what do you mean?
And related to dams and
the troubled landscape
but then this lead to another issue.
I'm very curious about
that something here.
What is the...
How do anthropologists like you
working on more than human
and a multi-species issue
to incorporate non-life forms?
Let's say dance, let's say
gigantic concrete monsters
non-organic beings.
How do you deal with that?
Not necessarily life-based.
Not necessarily species-based.
So I'm just purely curious
about what's the conversation
in your field about that.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Well, thank you so much.
Yeah. I think they're sort of...
They're all very much connected.
Yeah, I mean, in some ways,
it feels like multi-species
as a kind of approach,
isn't necessarily expensive enough
to incorporate everything
that we wanna talk about.
And so that's why I use
the term more than human
rather than multi-species
because a lot of my work has been,
has involved trying to
understand this incredibly
sort of powerful and really
quite problematic agency,
I guess
that these non-living beings
can have on people's lives
and how they kind of co-create
these sorts of realities.
And so this kind of brings me
to the notion of dams
and Troubled landscapes.
So these are basically
connected in the sense that
my paper, Troubled
landscapes was very much
an attempt to understand how effectively
my interlocutors were becoming displaced
from their own landscape,
their own kind of sort of
genealogical, social, moral space,
which they call (speaks
in foreign language)
which means basically our area
without ever having left it.
And this was...
That was where the sort of
troubledness came in, right?
That they were still living in this space
that was undergoing these
really quite radical
and far reaching physical changes
that then had implications
for the way they related to the land.
So in this article I wrote about how prior
to the dam coming along,
they sort of use things like
fruit trees and landmarks
and kind of bamboo, rows of
bamboo, old long house posts
as sort of indexes of their
genealogies and their movements
in the sort of migration
patterns across that land
which could in turn be ways of
understanding people's rights
and relationships and kinship
obligations in the present.
And of course, once the dam came along
and the landscape began
being kind of reshaped
in anticipation of inundation,
all of that started to
disappear really quickly.
So you didn't just have
this sudden dam landscape
that was opening up in front of them,
which they had to walk through.
It took...
I mean, it would take
about an hour sometimes
when the weather was bad to get
through this construction site.
And it was absolutely terrifying.
You'd have boulders kind of
falling down occasionally,
you'd have these burst water pipes,
you'd have these huge machines
that you'd have to somehow
pick your way around.
And people would always
talk about these things
as if they had a kind of malign
agency and force themselves.
Oh, so and so, one of
those workers fell off
that water tower or whatever recently
broke open his head, they buried him.
They didn't know where he came from.
You get all these stories
as you were kind of walking
through the dam construction site.
So I guess in that sense,
what was happening was
this really weird...
This weird sort of process of displacement
that didn't involve necessarily
a kind of relocation
or migration to a different site,
but that was nevertheless
completely reshaping people's lives.
So that's kind of what I meant.
And yeah, I mean, absolutely
the dam was a huge thing.
Not just the sort of big
physical cement structure
which is big, but also it's spectra.
It's possibility, which change things
and people's relations way
before the waters ever came.
And then when the waters
came, it was all about
how they was stinky and deadly and toxic.
And I mean, yeah, there were
many, many sort of affective
and very visceral associations
produced by these non-human
things including dams.
So, yeah, I don't think
multi-species is necessarily
a big enough term to
capture what was going on.
- Right, so in the sense
of the Troubled landscapes
creates a many new spirits
too in this new era?
Sounds like.
- Yeah, I think so. I think so.
I think we're still working that one out.
I mean, I know it upset many old spirits
so there were hauntings in the dormitory
that we heard about a lot,
it was all about the old
waterways getting blocked up
and spirits getting really off about that.
Yeah. There was all that going on as well.
There might...
I think they said there might be hauntings
by the spirits of the workers who died
but I haven't had anything since then.
So I don't know if that's still-
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- I believe we have a
question from James Scott
and then after Jim we have
questions from Ayesha Kashani,
Shoko Yamada and Kristin S.
And we have about 20 minutes left.
It's one o'clock for those of you
who have to leave at one o'clock sometime
but we have...
We can stick around a little longer.
So I'll let James take the question
and then we'll turn to the others.
Go ahead, James.
- Thanks a lot.
It was a wonderful talk and provocative.
What I wanted to ask
you to speculate about
is the relationship between monotheism
as an anthropological
reality on the ground
not in terms of its books and doctrine,
but Islam or Christianity
especially the hard edge
diversion that's recently come
and its relationship to the
non-human world generally.
I mean, one of the,
from an abstract perspective,
one of the attractions I think
to environmentalist of
animism is the presumption
that the non-human world
has agency spirit and so on
and therefore demands a
certain kind of respect.
I know Pfizer Zachary
was a colleague of yours
in history at NUS.
He's working on these issues in Sumatra.
But I'd like you to say
something about monotheism
on the ground as it's
understood and practiced
and whether it's relationship
to the non-human world
is different, radically
different, moderately different
from let's say the older
spirit loving practitioners
at your field site.
- Interesting, thank you very much
for putting that thought in my head.
It's hard for me to say whether or not
the Christians I'm familiar with
have a particularly strong
concept of monotheism.
I think they're sort of...
They're very aware that
the Christian god...
So I'm really speaking
from this underground experience here.
They're very aware that the
Christian god is the most...
Is the one true god
but that doesn't necessarily
make him the only god.
So I think as far as they're concerned
that the sort of...
One of the biggest
attractions of Christianity
when people initially converted
was that it was seen to free.
And they used the term bia, which means...
Which is a ritual term.
It means free from a ritual
taboo to free Bidayuhs
from the sort of
obligations and difficulties
and challenges and hardships
that were caused by
the old animus rituals.
Now, it's very hard to tell
whether this is a kind
of retrospective gloss
that people put on the old animus rituals
as a way of kind of
justifying their conversion
to Christianity.
But the sort of standard
story that you hear is
in the olden days things were really hard
because the spirits were
really unpredictable.
There were lots of (speaks
in foreign language)
lots of taboos that you might come across.
If you were walking to farm
and you had a busy day's
work harvesting the rice,
if you saw a bird flying
cost you three times
in a certain direction,
oh no you'd have to stop immediately
because that was an omen
and then you'd be punished
if you didn't obey it.
And so people often talked about
these very sort of unpredictable
but also very kind of
time-consuming restrictions
that they had to live with in the old days
as one of the main reasons that they chose
to convert to Christianity.
They were free.
And the reason they were free was not that
they didn't believe the old
spirits existed anymore.
It was that they realized
that the old spirits
were now being trumped
by more powerful spirit
which was god or Jesus
or Mary or whatever.
And they had weapons.
They had crucifixes,
altars, holy water and so on
with which they could kind of
combat any malign influences
whether it was Satan or
whether it was the old spirits
that were causing trouble for them.
So, I mean, it's hard to say whether
that is a form of
monotheism on the ground,
I suppose in the sense that theoretically
I think everyone subscribes
to a relatively purified model
of Christianity.
They will say the right things
and they know in theory what the story,
they call it stories is meant to be about.
In practice, I think it's
a much more difficult
sort of juggling act between
the sort of realities
of the Christian present
and the continued,
the persistent remnants of
the pre-Christian past that
I mean, they're just there.
They're not even possibilities
they're just there in people's lives.
And so I guess sort of relating this point
to the non-human world, I think
maybe one of of the things
that I find environmentalist
tend to get wrong
is kind of this assumption
that all indigenous people
love and care about and have
kin relations with and so on
non-human beings.
I don't think that's necessarily true.
I mean, when you sort of look at
these sorts of relations on the ground,
we find that people
would just as interested
in drawing boundaries
and very often people
would have kind of antagonistic relations
with certain beings and certain animals,
certain parts of nature,
however you define that.
And so I'm not sure
necessarily if Christianity
might've inacted a change
so much as that stereotype
about indigenous people
may not be all that true.
I'm generalizing a little bit here,
but certainly from what I've
seen in the Borneo context
that's not the case,
there's a much more kind of
complex range of emotions
and relations and boundaries that you see
in people's relations
with non-human spirits
and non-humans animals.
- Great, we'll move to the next question
from Ayesha Kashani.
- Hi, Liana.
Thank you for the time.
- [Liana] Hi.
Yeah, I mean, okay.
So I'm a PhD student
at Goldsmiths University of
London in visual cultures
and my work is looking at cosmic
politics and the histories
and futures of exhibiting
nature at the Sorel Museum.
And so I just wanted to ask,
I mean about your reference
to cosmic politics.
If you can speak a little bit
to the methodologies and practices
that you're working with
in terms of mediating
between conservationists and communities
and orangutans and the
state and everything else,
and how if you all using a kind
of cosmic political framework
in terms of negotiating between those
and how it's working out.
- Yeah, I think I use
it sort of selectively.
So, I mean, they're obviously
sort of different approaches
to cosmos politics.
The one that I'm finding
most useful at this point
is the one that's used
by Marisol de la Cadena
and her colleague, Mario Blaser
in relationship to sort
of indigenous groups
in North and South America.
And what these are sort of built around
are kind of ontological tarnish desire
to try and take their spirit beliefs,
their relations with things like
mountains, important
mountains, other spirits,
again, on ontological
turns and to actually
rather than kind of explaining
them away as just beliefs
or kind of cultural
glosses or superstitions,
trying to understand the
sort of political role
that these non-human entities can play
in their politics and their
relations with the state.
And I think the sort of
main thing that I take away
from this particular body of work is that
it advocates an approach to difference
and incommensurability quite specifically
that does not go for...
That does not go for a kind of hybrid
or neutralizing end, right?
So if you get, say four
different kind of increments,
rubble, complexes,
practices, people together,
what they sort of
advocate as a way for them
to kind of come together
through partial connections.
So this is what de la Cadena
drawing on (indistinct) uses,
but without allowing any
party to encompass or dominate
or run over the other such
that that original difference
is preserved, is maintained.
So it's a kind of...
It's a sort of alignment and
a way forward momentarily
without nullifying the
original difference.
And I think that is actually
a very useful approach
in various ways to,
particularly to orangutan conservation
where you've constantly got
conservationists and the state
trying to change mindsets.
This is a very popular phrase
in orangutan conservation.
You know, it's always like
how do we change these villages mindsets?
How do we change these
indigenous people's mindsets
and get them to love
orangutans, for example.
And I guess one of the
things I've been trying
to encourage conservationists
to think about
is how they can adopt
a slightly more cosmic
political approach to this
rather than trying to
completely change the way
these were all going to
just think about orangutans,
for example.
Can you sort of find ways through
that don't involve forcing them to adapt
to your particular values or
your particular assumptions
about sort of human-animal relations,
about about how special orangutans are?
And actually what I might
do is very quickly respond
to Michael's comment in the
texts because this is relevant.
This was...
The orangutan was kind of tabooed
in certain parts of Borneo.
But as far as I know, it was
not across the entire Island.
So I do know that there have
been various 19th century,
early 20th century sources
and some contemporary stories
particularly among various
Iban communities as you say
about how it has a special relationship
to contemporary villages
particularly in the way it was set
to teach humans how to give birth safely.
So the idea was that there's an Iban guy
who went out to the forest,
saw an orangutan mother
being helped to give birth
by other children.
And that persuaded the Iban
men to stop the old practice
of apparently cutting
open women's stomachs
when they gave birth, which
was probably quite bad
and adopt this method of
helping to massage out
and the child.
So there are certain villages
in which historically the
orangutan was a special
and taboo creature,
but that's not as far as I can
tell widespread across Borneo
and it's not called it...
It's not necessarily different
to any other villages special
relation with other animals.
So it may not be an orangutan.
It might be a snake or a crocodile
or a particular bird or something else.
And again to go back to Ayesha's point
this is where it is quite
important to try and avoid
sort of stereotypical or generalized views
about the kind of difference
that you're trying to
overcome as a conservationist.
There are many conservationists
who jumped on this idea of the orangutan
as a tabooed animal was a special animal
to very, very specific
communities, Iban communities
in the past.
And they say, well we wanna help them
remember their old rituals.
Let's do it.
And I guess my question is,
is there sort of a
better way of doing this
that somehow allows them sort
of respects that difference
and allows them to sort
of find a way through
without trying to nullify
their distinctiveness.
- I see that Jim wanted to jump in.
Jim, you had your hand up really quick.
Is it...
Did you have something
you wanted to jump in
or can I jump to Shoko and Kristin?
Okay, Shoko Yamada who is a PhD student
in the anthropology and school
of environment here at Yale
has a question.
- Hi, thank you so much for this talk.
I was fascinating constantly throughout
and I especially love example
you were talking about
in terms of the heterogeneity of ontology
how there's like not a single ontology
that you could talk about on the ground.
And I was thinking about
in relation to maybe
Michael's earlier question
about transition and
Borneo being in transition
and the fact that when
you are doing field work
a lot of people are
going through conversion
to Christianity or relatively recently
and going through this change.
And I was thinking about how
maybe we could think about
that as like another form of
heterogeneity almost across,
not in terms of like space
where like lots of people
are disagreeing about stuff
and debating about things
that kind of a heterogeneity across time
within the supposedly same single self.
So I was...
I guess I have two
related questions on this.
One is just on the ground
how people are living
through and grappling with
this kind of transition
or maybe like whether you, or I just hope,
like with our there's a
sense of contradiction,
is there a sense of nostalgia tars,
a different kind of paths,
or is it seen as progress?
I'm just kind of curious
how ethnographically
how people are dealing with this.
And the second one is I
guess is a little more
the theoretical one in
terms of your critique
of the ontological turn and how
and kind of I guess the question
about how the parent might
or might not be able to deal
with this kind of
historical change over time.
And yeah, so I was kind of wondering
if you could speak about that
and how you are a guest suggestion to deal
with more of the co-presence
between the ethnography person
and the interlocutors
as opposed to kind of the
radical alternative might
or might not help us kind of deal
with this kind of change
that the term might
or might not miss.
Yeah, those are it's a lot, but yeah.
If you could speak any speak
to any aspect with them.
- Yeah. Thank you very much.
I mean, that's...
Yeah, that's a really nice
way of articulating it.
Thank you.
Yeah. Heterogeneity across time.
That's a really good point.
And I mean, there've been
sort of various critiques
of the ontological turn
that kind of also point out
how that they're not
necessarily very helpfully,
constantly dealing with the ways
in which people's views
or approaches or selves
and relations might change over time.
So I think you're absolutely right.
How would people living
through transition?
Yeah, one way which I
find really interesting
and which also in some
ways kind of broaden
my kind of anti-colonial
sensibilities I guess.
One thing I found really
interesting is that
there's been a kind of
romanticization of the British past.
Zimmerman British, German,
German as they say.
And by British, Bidayuhs tend to mean
both the British colonial government
and the Brooke Raj,
which was a curious beast
that roots row up in
the century before that.
And what is interesting here is that
there is a kind of nostalgia developing
around how in the olden days,
the British would care for
where they were kindly
women, this kind generous,
they would care for people like themselves
because they wouldn't
eat their land, right?
This is a term they use.
They don't...
The British did not eat our land.
And they gave us some development.
They gave us rubber plantations,
they gave us water tanks.
They brought Christianity
who brought education
and medicines.
And this is then used
as a kind of moral foil
to the contemporary Malaysian government
which they see as only ever
wanting to eat their lands.
And the fear of land
grabs is quite sort of
justified in Sarawak
and also withholding development from them
because they're not Muslim.
And so there's a really
interesting kind of...
It's almost like a sort of donate to cue
where you've kind of got
this romanticized Brooke British past
set against what they say is a
very, very unpleasant reality
of sort of Malaysian present.
And I suppose what's really
interesting about this.
And I guess this sort of goes back
to this question of co-presence
and historicity as well.
Is that what...
I think what people are
invoking here is not so much
a sort of absolutely good British past
but a kind of ideal relationship
with a benevolent state
which they've kind of
come to see as a baseline.
So as far as they're concerned,
the British government, as they say,
kind of laid...
It set the standards for
what their relationship
with the state should be like.
The state should take care of them
but it should not eat their lands.
And what they want from
the Malaysian government
is a return to that relationship.
Give us development but
don't take our lands.
And there's an interesting
sort of constant hopefulness
about the way they sort
of engage with politicians
and with development
projects that they think,
well, maybe this will work,
maybe this time this
project might actually
give us development and work
and still allow us to keep our land.
So there's a very interesting
kind of eternal optimism
at play here that comes with
that nostalgia, I think.
And so I guess they've got
their own sort of projections, right?
They've got their own sort of
future speculative projects
about how at some point they will return
to this kind of ideal governments,
this ideal Bidayuh state relationship.
And I think that is
particularly interesting
because that is them trying
to project themselves
into what I described earlier
as a very powerful homogenizing force.
You know, it's them basically saying,
well, we don't wanna
be completely eaten up
by the Malaysian state
but we really do wanna be Malaysian.
We really do believe in
being Malaysian citizens
and we want our rights,
we want the development
and the other good things that would do
so please don't forget us.
And that is a form of co-presence
that they're constantly asserting
but also a form of sameness.
Which I find a really interesting kind of
idea to deal with, I guess
partly because it sort of,
it probably sort of pushes up against
my own kind of anthropological instincts,
which is why do you wanna do this?
But I guess it's pragmatic.
They wanna be Malaysians.
They wanna be part of the state
that it's sort of my job to
try and understand how and why.
- Thank you, Liana.
Liana, we're getting close to 1:20.
I have time, but I am mindful of...
I didn't tell you how
long we would keep you.
And if you have the energy
you can answer as long as you wish
but we have two more questions
to that I'd like to hear.
Would you like to hear both
questions at the same time?
Or should I go one at a time?
- I don't mind.
- It's okay.
So we'll go with Kristin S first.
And Kristin if you can introduce yourself.
- [Kristin] Hello, thank you very much.
I wanted to ask you about
to reflect a little bit,
if possible what scene...
We seem to be so comfortable glossing over
the influence of Christianity
and this homogenizing
force that you speak of
and even in the way in
which it contributes
to this shaping of what you...
Of what the relationship
with the state should be,
and that in all of our understanding
currently suggests that the
great importance of biodiversity
and how do we...
It's so troubling to me to hear the way
in which you describe young people
not wanting to have even to be...
Have any understanding of their origin,
of their cultural identity
because they've been so
brainwashed to believe
that somehow this is going
to be detrimental to them.
And why is that we have this
notion that somehow crucifixes
and are valid tools for
protection and that,
and how is it that we become as academics
often so comfortable with
this dispassionate observation
of the loss of a language of
a whole body of knowledge,
this hierarchical valuing of
what is the gift of understanding
that we're bringing in education
and the arrogance that we show
in not how do we overcome this sense
of trying to actually learn from cultures
that have been in existence
for thousands of years
very successfully and
actually expand our knowledge
as opposed to contracting
it and making it smaller?
- Sure. Yeah.
No, thank you.
I mean, I have to say this is something
that troubles me a lot as well.
And what I...
Earlier on, I kind of said,
I went into this research
very, very hostile towards
missionaries and Christianity
precisely because of this problem.
But I think this is where
we do have one of those
sort of classic ethical
tensions in anthropology,
which is actually very,
very difficult to get round.
And this is this...
And that is this question of how...
Of what you do if the people
that you're working with
fervently and wholeheartedly
subscribe to something
and believe in something
and craft their lives
around something that you
personally might find repugnant
or find extremely problematic.
And I do find Christianity
extremely problematic
in all sorts of ways,
but I also acknowledge
that if I were to approach
the field work that I did
from that starting point,
I wouldn't have been able to
do field work in this village.
I would not have been able
to understand very much
about my interlocutors lives.
And so I guess, yes, I mean, in this case
I did make a choice to suspend
my sort of personal concerns
about the influence and the
very detrimental influence
that Christianity has had
in all sorts of societies.
And to actually try to
understand what it was
about Christianity that was
so powerful in people's lives,
how it was changing their lives.
And that was basically
something I had to do
in order to understand the
people that I was living with.
I guess the other thing
to sort of say is that
in many ways, the young
people have embraced
aspects of their past.
The Bidayuh language is not dying.
People are still actively
speaking in the villages,
it's busy...
People are basically recreating
it and playing around
with it on social media.
It has been absolutely fascinating
kind of watching new kinds of terminology,
new spellings emerge on
Facebook with my friends,
where they really are kind of...
It is still very much a living language.
And there are also many other aspects
of kind of earlier bits of non-animus life
that have not completely been squashed.
So I think in that sense,
what they were very concerned
about was a very specific
aspect of the old ways
which was precisely how you
relate to the old spirits
and how that might actually
cause trouble for them
how it might actually put
them in personal danger.
And this was a very deeply felt concern.
It wasn't just, I don't
wanna know about my,
the old ways because I'm Christian.
No, it was kind of like, if I
inadvertently screw up on this
my child could die.
And it was, I didn't really
feel that it was my place
to then come in there and say,
well, actually you're doing things wrong
because you are disrespecting your old,
the the old ways, your old culture.
I mean, I certainly felt
it, but it was not...
I felt my place to pass
that sort of judgment
during my field work.
And so I did maintain a
certain sort of agnosticism
about what I was studying
and trying to understand.
And I mean, it was also very interesting
that the elderly
practitioners were very...
They were quite sort of blaise about it,
which I also found interesting.
And they said, well, life ways
are changing all the times,
rituals change,
the old spirits are gonna
become Christian eventually
or they might just go off
to their homes in the hills
and the rivers, because
we're always changing.
So I guess it was that aspect
of Christian conversion
that I was trying to understand
and how actually the sort of Christianity,
this sort of Christian life
did come to suffuse relations
in the village.
Yeah, and it felt
uncomfortable at many points,
but I guess in terms of
trying to actually empathize
and understand my interlocutors lives
that was kind of suspension
of my own doubt that I had to take.
- Thank you, Liana.
It reminded me of something
you said earlier too
about when you were talking about ontology
about the need to have a kind
of humility as an anthropology
or a humble anthropology that
you had talked about before.
We'll take the last
question from David Lindsay.
- Thank you.
Thank you for this talk
has been very interesting.
Regarding the people you have focused on,
are the older ways in general
more environmentally conscious
than the new Christian views?
Do these people become less
or more environmentally conscious
with embracing Christianity?
- Yeah, that's a tough one to answer.
It's a tough one to answer
because the sort of big push
to convert to Christianity
went hand in hand
with a move away from rice planting.
And so there were, for
example and there still are
various kind of traditional
ways of, I guess
what we would now call them
sustainable farming, right?
Which people still observe.
So you know, for example, there was a...
There are certain kind of areas of land
that are set aside for
use by the community.
You know not a single household
which is the usual unit of
ownership but a community
and people are allowed
to sort of take turns
cultivating that piece of land.
But then the sort of general
understanding is that
if the (speaks in foreign language)
which is like the spirit of the place
finds that there's one family
that's been over cultivating
it or doing too much
then it gets really cross
and then your crop fails.
So just don't do that.
And people are actually
quite good at following that.
They may or may not say it's to do with
(speaks in foreign language) now,
even though they...
Generally, there's an understanding
that the (speaks in foreign
language) still exists
but they're generally quite
good even including today
in Christian villages
at following that rule.
So you could say in some ways
that actually it's not really
made a huge difference.
I think the sort of bigger change has been
just with sort of development
and the extension of
infrastructure to these villages.
So the village where I did my PhD
had a road built, a
TOD road extended to it
in the sort of 19, late 1990s.
So it was...
It had been a very sort of
Stony gravel road before that.
And it was TOD
and that caused a huge demographic shift
in people effectively
becoming village commuters,
they go to school and work
in urban areas, earn wages.
They came back, they lived in the village,
they'd be villages.
And so that actually meant that they...
Most of them were not relying on
subsistence farming anymore.
So it was...
You'd still have...
People would still cultivate their land
because they were afraid of land grabs.
So there was a kind of political point.
They didn't want the state to come in
and see these seemingly unused
or abandoned pieces of land
and say, oh, we're gonna take those.
It was very much a case of,
no, we're gonna keep our lands going
even if we're never gonna
feed ourselves from it.
So, I mean, it's a tricky one
because you can't really separate
the conversion to Christianity
from the urbanization process.
In a way there's just been much less done
to the local environment
since people are started
converting to Christianity
but that's nothing...
That's got nothing to
do with Christianity.
It's just got to do with urbanization.
- [David] Yeah. Thank you.
- Well, thank you, Liana.
This has been a fascinating conversation.
I really appreciate you taking
so much time with us today
to share so much about your
long-term ongoing research
in Borneo.
I'm gonna bring the session to a close.
There is a question for you in the chat
that if you wanna respond
you can send me the answer
and I'll send it to the quest audience,
but I think it is now 1:30
so we should bring it to a close.
So everyone join me in thanking Liana Chua
for such a wonderful talk.
And we'll see you in two weeks
for a talk with James
Scott on the Irrawaddy
and Liana, you're welcome
to join us for that
if you're interested.
- Thank you very much.
It was lovely to meet everyone sort of.
- Thank you.
- [Liana] Yes.